how are you doing sir good you know a
little jet lag but all right all right
I'm very familiar yeah a few quick
questions uh I am curious what do you
think fans will be thinking or what do
you think their reaction is going to be
as episode 8 of the Mandalorian ends of
season three
that's an interesting question
I mean I have such boring answers
sometimes right I hope they really
enjoyed it you know I mean I think
they'll have a lot to think about
they'll have a lot to take in and I
think with any good ending you know
there's the moment you're in it where
you're cheering and you feel satisfied
but then there is a little bit after
that where you think back at all the
things that happened and maybe you start
to put them together in a different way
and you realize it's an ending but there
are other things happening out there in
the galaxy
that now you know more about and you
might learn a little bit more about this
weekend depending on what panel you go
to so you know we'll have to see but
yeah I just hope you know the fans have
been so good you're right maybe that's
about but the fans have been so great to
me and John and and the you know his
creation of the Mandalorian is so unique
and special uh I hope they feel really
good about it I hope it's a they're all
cheering and and uh excited for the
outcome whatever that may be so I'll
admit that I'm I'm so excited about
these new movies but I am a little bit
as a fan I was in the room I was a
little bit confused as to like exactly
what your movie is so what can you tell
people about what your movie is very
little of course very little I mean I
think that the way I've been describing
it is I think if you grew up when I did
uh you know you're aware of the post
Return of the Jedi era that kind of was
presented to me like the new Republic is
not a new idea that's not something
Mandalorian created that's an old idea
it's been around a long time they're
just things in Star Wars that we all
seem to know if we've been out around it
a long time there have been a lot of
tremendous creatives over the years that
have been telling stories in the era
that you know spans the 30 years that
now
ends up at Force awakens but there's a
large gap of time there so there is a
story to be told you know the new
Republic just just sit there idly and
Happy Days for all that time obviously
because things aren't that great we'll
begin with the force awakens so John and
I looked at that time period and when he
knew he won the Mandalorian in it one of
the things that I told him early on was
well
I have this epilogue and stars Rebels
it's kind of dealing with that time
period
um which you know as you've seen at the
end with Sabine and Ahsoka going off so
a lot of those threats start to come
together and then I look at the bigger
body of work that's been done and what's
relevant and a story will emerge out of
that so can I just ask you who is
writing this are you writing the script
who's who's doing it I'm not going to
say much about that but I will be
involved in the writing for sure yeah
for sure I've heard Rumblings that
perhaps the Mandalorian season four
could be filming later this year is that
is that true
I'm trying to be fair here without
giving anything away I would say you
know John said he wrote it all I'm not
my words his words I'm going to say
they're in trouble I'm gonna say that I
I'm I'm willing to place a large wager
it's filming later this year and would I
lose money
it's interesting you know I would say
they're I gotta say this and feel bad
about it but it's like that's a that's a
better way to right now maybe
um more solid ground than if my penguins
are going to make the playoffs because
we only have three games left we're one
point behind we gotta win out that's
gonna be tough but I believe in the boys
I think they can get it done so we'll
see I mean maybe if the Penguins make
the playoffs my answers will get better
so we have we all have that to look
forward to